russia is continuing its attacks on
defence facilities across ukraine
including fuel depots with this site in
the western city of lutsk getting hit
overnight
with talks expected to start between the
two warring sides ukraine's president
vladimir zelensky has struck a
conciliatory tone
he seems to accept russia's military
presence in some parts of ukraine in
some form as part of any
i understand it's impossible to make
russia give up territory completely that
will lead to world war three i
understand completely i'm aware
he's also confirmed he is willing to
consider ukrainian neutrality in the
future provided president putin pulls
back his forces
on ukraine's western border with poland
there's relative order after the chaotic
exodus of refugees in recent weeks in
the early days of the conflict with tens
of thousands of people leaving ukraine
every day this was one of the busiest
crossings with people lining up for a
whole day just to get across into poland
the numbers of people leaving has
declined significantly and there's also
now been an increase in people coming
the other way maria is coming back from
the czech republic after leaving her
hometown in eastern ukraine that's now
occupied by the russians
i decided to come back because my
husband is here and it's very hard to be
away from him i was sad much emotions
left the eastern city of dinipro nearly
two weeks ago but is now returning also
i'm coming back to check on my mother
and see what the situation is like my
daughter is 14 and i've left her with my
older daughter in poland
any peace talks are likely to include
the future of the bitterly contested
coastal strip from russian-controlled
crimea to the breakaway eastern regions
in the donbass president zielenski has
revealed he is in regular contact with
troops in the besieged city of mariupol
and seems to accept they face
overwhelming odds
if you feel it's the right thing to do
then do it
but he also says so far his soldiers
have refused to give in rob mcbride al
jazeera leviev
now the un secretary general has called
for an immediate ceasefire in ukraine
antonio guterres said it would help both
russia and ukraine find a political
solution to the conflict
the solution to this humanitarian
tragedy is not humanitarian it is
political
i'm therefore appealing for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire to allow for
progress in serious political
negotiations
aiming at reaching a peace agreement
based on the principles of the united
nations charter
a cessation of hostilities will allow
essential humanitarian aid to be
delivered
and enable civilians to move around
safely
and kristen salumi joins us now from the
un headquarters in new york so we heard
the appeal there of antonio guterres how
much traction is that call for an
immediate ceasefire gaining though
amongst member states
well what we heard is the secretary
general attempting to capitalize on a
general assembly resolution that was
passed late last week calling for just
that a humanitarian cessation of
hostilities a ceasefire the term that he
used even stronger term
the general assembly directed that call
at russia
140 countries supported it obviously
there's immense concern at the united
nations about the humanitarian spillover
not only just the impact on ukraine but
on other countries in the region and the
world who rely on ukraine for grain the
impact on food prices and so on
tempting
potentially spilling over and elsewhere
into the conflict so
what we heard was secretary general
antonio guterres talking about efforts
that he has implemented including naming
humanitarian chief martin griffis to
take on the job of attempting to work
on a cessation of hostilities for
humanitarian purposes which could then
lead the way to more substantive peace
talks because as we just heard there he
acknowledged that any lasting piece
will have to be based on a political
solution not just the humanitarian
solution but using that humanitarian
urgency as a common ground as a way to
move things forward we'll see if the
sides
listen in any way but he mentioned that
he already has a
un staff on the ground in moscow and
engaging with all sides in the conflict
to try to make that happen
right kristin take us through the
remarks mr guterres made after that
press conference about the russian
president what did he have to say
well you know interesting remarks the
united nations secretary general is
always very diplomatic it's part of his
job not to
take sides in a conflict he has been
critical of president putin in calling
on him to end the war and end the
aggression because of the impact it's
having on civilians and so on there but
he was specifically asked about
president joe biden of the united states
and the comments he made over the
weekend saying that
president putin can no longer stay in
power when asked
about that guterres said very
quickly and succinctly that there needs
to be a de-escalation not only of
fighting but also
of rhetoric again
the united nations attempting to keep
the focus on international law as the
basis for anything that it does and the
criticism of russia has been that it's
violating national sovereignty so the
united states calling uh for something
uh on the ground in another country is
not something that the united nations is
is likely to get behind an attempt to
keep a more neutral focus and attempt on
a cessation of hostilities based on
something that all members of the united
nations general assembly have expressed
concern on in some way and that is the
humanitarian situation all right thanks
so much kristen salumi
now mario paul is on the verge of a
humanitarian catastrophe according to
its mayor who's calling for a complete
evacuation about 160 000 civilians
remain trapped in the besieged port city
the ukrainian deputy prime minister says
no new humanitarian corridors are open
after reports of possible provocations
along the routes
russia has denied targeting civilians
close to four million refugees are
estimated to have fled ukraine since the
war began late last month and volunteers
from around the world are flooding into
neighbouring countries like poland to
help care for them but this is creating
its own problems kimberly halkid is in
joshua one of poland's main refugee
reception points
all right let's go over to her live
there she joins us from there so
kimberly how much coordination are you
seeing actually on the ground between
aid organizations
incredibly there is almost no
coordination that is what surprised us
when we visited the medica border
crossing which is not far from where i'm
standing right now what we found when we
got there was as people crossed into
poland from ukraine on foot they were
overwhelmed by what they found on the
other side this kind of patchwork of
in most cases good intentioned people
but with really no organization of
purpose in other words what they found
were people who decided to get on a
plane and come and help
but with no official backing behind them
there were ngos that nobody had ever
heard of and there were also even
private companies who said they were
there to help but really in more ways
than one we're pushing their latest
product and what this has led to are
people crossing ukraine kind of fleeing
one danger for another
in that they don't have a plan many of
them they were so focused on getting out
of ukraine they didn't think about what
would happen when they crossed into
poland and what they would do next and
that has left them open to the
suggestion and the power of suggestion
of people they can't necessarily trust
and as a result this has left a lot of
refugees particularly vulnerable
i'm kimberly
when we talk about those most at risk
what kind of assistance are they getting
there
well
those most at risk tend to be women they
tend to be children and we even saw
elderly and disabled that were
not getting the services that they
needed because there's absolutely no one
in charge there's no coordination and
as a result we talked to the authorities
in this area we talked to local police
and said what are you doing to
investigate the people that are showing
up to help how are you checking their
backgrounds and they said they aren't
it's not our problem we don't we're not
tasked with this responsibility in any
way these people are just passing
through so it's really nothing to worry
about but the problem is is that we're
hearing that a lot of people are
becoming victim and falling victim to
the unscrupulous and
what this has really led to is the fact
that since there is no one vetting the
aid is overwhelming
what this has really opened up is
another industry that people don't want
to admit and that is human trafficking
and that's what we're going to be
looking at a tuesday on al jazeera this
industry that has sprung up
one that the police say doesn't exist
and is misinformation even as they're
handing out pamphlets at the medical
border crossing saying this is what you
need to look out for if you want to
protect yourself so it's a controversial
issue no one wants to talk about but
it's one that's on the rise
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much kimberly